TONY PADILLA: We're going to
do Buffon's needle trick.
So this is named after Georges
Louie Leclerc, and this is a
method that he proposed
for working out pi.
So basically he proposed that
you would chuck a bunch of
needles just randomly
on a floor.
You can work out pi
from that, yeah.
BRADY HARAN: Go on, then.
TONY PADILLA: Due to
the random nature.
So anyway, we haven't got
needles, and we're not going
to do it on a floor.
We're going to do it on
one of Brady's lovely
brown pieces of paper.
And we're going to use matches
instead, because we're cheap.
So what we want is we want to
draw some lines on this.
So there's one line.
And what we want is we want the
gaps between lines to be
two matches long.
This is all very approximate.
What we're going to do is we're
going to chuck a bunch
of matches on this board.
So I'll just chuck the first
two completely randomly.
We need a lot of matches
for this.
If I counted these right,
we should have 163.
Let's just spread them out.
So hopefully, there should
be 163 matches randomly
distributed around this board.
Now, this is what I've gotta do
now, is I'm going to count
how many matches cross a line.
OK, so I reckon that one does.
So you count, Brady,
that was 1, 2, 3.
5, 6, 11, 12.
13, 14, 51, and I
think that's it.
52.
52 matches that cross
the lines.
There's 163 in total.
Now, let's see.
Let's do the following
calculation.
So 163 divided by 52
is equal to 3.13.
And that's not bad.
That's not bad, I'm quite
happy with that.
BRADY HARAN: That's
very close.
TONY PADILLA: Yeah, yeah.
So pi is 3.141.
So this is not bad.
OK, so why isn't it perfect?
Because this is not a
very large sample.
Viewers could have a little
go themselves.
Just literally play
the same game.
If you've got more matches,
that's better.
You'll get a better accuracy.
There was a mathematician
called Lazarine.
He used over 3,000 needles, and
he actually managed to get
pi accurate to I think it was
about six decimal places.
What we're seeing here is
something is akin to a Monte
Carlo simulation.
That's what it's called.
You basically take
a random sample.
The reason you get pie out of
this is it's all to do with
the angle that the match takes
as playing some role here.
And of course if you're working
in radians, if you go
through a full 360 degrees,
well, in radians that's 2 pi.
OK, so that's where pi's coming
into this game, and
that's why you can get pi
out of this sort of
setup, because the angle.
So we're going to try and
explain the maths of it now.
Let me say, imagine that the
length of the match is l, and
that means that the distance
here is 2l.
There's a few things that
play a role here.
There's the position of the
center of the match, which
I'll call there.
We'll say that's a distance
x from here.
And then the other thing that
we're interested in is the
angle the match is making.
So let's just draw it,
I guess, like so.
We're interested in
that angle beta.
Assuming everything's
completely random.
how do we measure the
probability of where the
center of the match is?
Well, the probability density
of the center of the match,
which is position x, is just
given by essentially 1/l.
The other thing that we're
interested in is
the angle it makes.
So this is sort of a measure
of the probability of the
angle it's making.
And basically, the angles that
we're interested in are
somewhere between 0 and pi/2
which is of course 90 degrees.
This is where the
pi's coming in.
Now, if we want to work out
essentially the probability
for the match to cross the
line, what we do is
we take these two.
We have to do an integration.
OK, now there's an important
point here.
What's the condition for the
match to cross the line?
Well, the condition for the
match to cross the line is
that x should be less
than l/2 sine theta.
So that means when we do the x
integration, we go between 0
and l/2 sine theta.
OK, and of course when we do the
theta integration, we're
going between 0 and pi by 2.
So we do it, theta equals 0,
this is pi/2, 2 over l pi.
2 over l pi.
When we do the x integration, we
get an l over 2 sine theta.
And then we integrate sine theta
between 0 and pi by 2.
That gives me 1, and I've
got the 1/pi there, so
the answer is 1/pi.
This tells me the probability
that you're going to cross the
line, right?
So if I've got n matches, and
I want to work out how many
cross, let me call them--
so this is the n total.
And I want to work out
how many cross.
Then I just multiply
and total that.
1/pi.
So n total is 163.
And n crossing was 52, I think
we got, didn't we?
OK.
So what you see from that
if we've got 163/pi.
Let's put an approximate
sign in there.
Approximately 52, or if you
like, what we actually saw was
that pi, just rearrange
this equation, so
approximately 163/52.
Yeah, I'm happy with that.
Yeah, yeah.
That's good.
So that's how it works.
That's the theory behind it.